[Music]
me
well
i
[Music]
e
i
[Music]
ah
a
[Music]
[Applause]
and
no no
welcome to what is the rapid san luís
and clips we are very excited
because well in a few minutes
we will have a tournament in action from baku in action
from saint louis missouri
a live broadcast with the
great master alejandro ramírez and his
most international chess friend and see
garcía well we want  still here he
is again seeing garry kasparov the
champion of champions returning to
the boards an incredible experience
we are going to have here the next five
days where gaby will be facing
the best of the best in the world in
rapid and blitz and well what  emotion
we are really having here not
since yesterday in what was at the
opening ceremony an impressive energy was felt
in the great master the legend the legend
gary kasparov the truth is how you
felt it  yer
I think that yesterday the
gal is over and that he is giving autographs that he is
smiling that he talks about politics
the great champion did not return
you will be it I hear him concentrated
do not go doing numbers I do not know with
whom I am going to judge that I am going  to play he has
prepared that is obvious and we are going to see
exactly how he is going to do here in the
first three rounds of rapids
we will have you today
I am simply very excited
really excited and well today
we will have all three  first games of
what is the fast rhythm let's remember that there
are nine rounds in total of the
fast rhythm and that good the value is double
if the fast games are worth double the
blitz so it will be two points for winning
a point for draws and zero for  lose
let's remember that the time control will be
25 minutes to play
with 10 seconds of delay there
is no increase it is a slight difference that
is quite important because
people are given back the 10 seconds  If
they think they cannot be increased
beyond what has arrived, of course they
are 10 seconds late and there are nine
rounds nine rounds today there will be
three tomorrow another three and
then three and the last two days
are 18  rounds 18 rounds if we will have
nine rounds it must be Thursday nine
rounds of blitz on Friday to end
the tournament here we still have incredible
wow incredible prizes incredible
pareos incredible games where do
we start to see well well let's go with
the prizes with the prizes that this
time go  What awards we have a
total of 150,000 dollars in prize money
in this great tournament where the first
place gets 37 thousand 500 dollars,
the second place 25 thousand dollars the
third 20 thousand dollars the fourth 15 thousand
the fifth 12 thousand 500 the sixth 10,000 and
well  from seventh to tenth from seventh
to tenth place take seven thousand
five hundred dollars
impressive impressive what we are going
to have here are really at stake
and  to a fairly serious tournament it's not in the
mood some exhibition tournament or more
than a couple of days really here it is a
tournament already quite serious the
players are playing not only for the
prizes that I see but also those who are
part of the tour are playing
Precisely because of the points of the tour
to try to put pressure on the
current leaders who are also
cause and passion for grace and let us remember
that since both the French and the Norwegian
and she played paris and luv in that
we put that any player on the tour
can only  play two rapid and
blitz events as they have already played 2 they cannot
take the third and that is why they are not here
if it would have been very interesting to have a
gentleman look for himself in a pothole who was
the winner of the champions and well what do
you think if we see what  what is he
the players the standings
if we go kasparov carjacking this
first round of rapids we will have
cash stoppage against load here a duel of
russians definitely the new era
against the  life the old guard here with
garry kasparov of course the best player not
only in russia from the soviet union
when he was back then and but in the
world for many years 15 years to be
there at the top and we are here we are
here against the best of russia the  challenger
against last year's world champion
sergey karjakin youngest grandmaster
in history well let's remember that he
got his title and grandmaster
only at 12 years old yes at 12 years old
without a doubt a star last year's challenger of
the current champion  of the world
magnus carlsen and well we will have
what your forecasts are it
is difficult I think we are going with the
series guideline that would make an extremely
solid player go to play against the
aggressive gari kasparov who knows that one comes
to return here to play the best he
can but  it's two years of retirement it's
two in the double shot it
starts with white the grandmaster
garry kasparov let's see if he can
beat up to what quality who we
remember what ma  gnus carlsen had to
take it to the rapids to win
the world championship well we have a
carjacking who is better known as the
minister of defense and what a
game
i am going back to feng that game let's
see white kasparov first
good with everything nakamura al  mar the capture
also what forecast do we have there they
speak has always been he has had
problems against a camera really and
nakamura is an extremely fast player
he specializes in the fast one he
specializes in the blitz he is for me one
of the favorites and not the favorite to
win everything  the nakamura tournament despite the fact
that he has had a lousy tournament now in
the cup it means that he has just finished
really he is a player who strives
and improves the less time there is
on the veil so for mine
a great favorite dies but they win the
same annan as last year with this
same pace of play against the camera
precisely topálov and carvana and
devastates them like this this one for me is going to be  r duel
of favorites because I think they are both
very very fast and fast that they
specialize in this type of system or
how well against the
American grandmaster fabiano caruana that well
we have to talk about who elected
anguiano maybe you are not so
familiar  i'm still in the
vietnamese grandmaster le quang liem but he's the
best of the best he's been
world champion leeds he has more than 2700 of him
or he's playing a hundred
imagine who is when i think 3
of his whole life he's young he's 26  years he
just graduated from university
imagine this guy coming with
everything
and 2013 then without a doubt we have here a
great player that we must definitely not lose
sight of for me that it will
be a great duel and fabiano who has
had a lot of problems in  what
speed and blitz homeland that is very
careful of course he was also
world champion of under 14 also in
the 2005 championship and well we can not lose
sight of him and how  Well, in
this round he plays against Fabiano Caruana,
what do you think
[Music]
and all the players who are
invited change him so that they can play
a good tournament.
tournament he had in
the cup no row until magnus
beat him in the last round and well he is
playing against a prodigy it really
is life vara from the czech republic
elite grandmaster he just hasn't
had a chance to show his
talent really seven times champion  from the
czech republic as a seven-time
champion he also won the
european blitz championship in 2014 and well a
great master with 2,737 ice and
definitely for me the last pareo
extremely important for all of
us who are accompanying us the best player
in latin
america lenier domínguez pérez  he is here with
us in the rapid games and he
faces the black pieces they find
nepomniac  htchi I'm going to come and we're definitely going to play
this game and we're starting we're starting it we're starting
the duels we already have the first round
here between gary kasparov and sergey
karjakin and we're going straight to chess
we don't have gas an Indian announcement
between each other between garry kasparov from arica
is  forever played more than two queens out
of two the classic thing not going back to his
1985 duel yes wow
amazing how we started I knew he
was going to play just two knew it
and well maybe we'll have it here every year
inside the park  what is going to happen here
queen f5 what
sergey karjakin is playing
and we keep them on camera so we can
see we have on camera what we have
on camera so we can see there the game
of the duel between gary kasparov and sergey
karjakin which is definitely going to be the
duel that  we are going to follow more closely
today
yes well we have the duel here thanks to
all of you for continuing to follow this
transmission to enjoy
thank you very much and send  please give us your
comments your questions also
suggestions send us here we will be
very attentive in the chat
definitely well here we are
more or less finishing the opening
where obviously it is a game a little
less theoretical than we would expect
because gaspar or well 12  years of retirement
he is not going to play the main lines no
but here you have this idea of h3 that has l
ft karjakin thinking a very
nusual idea is h3 maybe he really wants
to play a g4 and go there he quick
y attacked the attack what
o you think i think  that this is going to be very
dangerous for caspa 2
or maybe you can consider
if a g4 and start attacking in this
position
well I know to take here a little bit it
will take a little bit
to 5 to 5 play then and quickly
play it goes forward here
he has to do 6 he did it right yes of
course he doesn't have much choice there and a33
and he plays very fast we don't see the
preparation of garry kasparov who comes
here with ideas that he is the  great sergey
karjakin who had a
world championship last year and surprises us in
an opening of
course we see a cash stop that undoubtedly
comes with everything he had a preparation
what do you think what kind of preparation and I
think he has definitely been here
with some player  of the
North American elite definitely because you
know that Kasparov spends it here in the
USA and in New York a lot but we
don't know exactly there are rumors there are
rumors that Alexander
Onischuk was the one who was half
training him they are the rumors but they are
pure rumors for  here amps have
said that they are going to connect to walk
to laugh down
at the same time as the club but that nobody knows
what the suspect is doing here
well we already know we already
know what kind of preparation the
baku ogre had look he is a legend so right
now  is playing is because he had
a preparation, he definitely does not come
with everything,
he is not going to risk coming here and
having a bad tournament, otherwise he is not going to
start  Definitely, greetings
to Venezuela, thanks for following this
transmission, greetings to Spain,
as always, they are
cheering, thank you very much for following
this transmission,
and well, let's see what else we have here,
let's remember that we also have other
games to follow, this one goes  to be the
main one where well what would someone who is
still a little slower than kasparov do,
we see time we are 24 minutes with
22 minutes on the part of change here and
quickly playing the incisor like this
definitely that style and well it is
active even the gary kasparov there it
we have playing against sergey
karjakin and well it would make us who are
still really thinking what
is going on in the position well the
first thing to think black has lost
the bishop walls but it compensates
because for the moment he has control
over the e4 square  what black is going to try
to do is very simple a
plan to get the white squares
for example  putting a knight on b3 they
played is 5 and bishops 6 all these types
of breaks or openings on the
white squares will benefit him a
lot, for example this one plays that has
just been a knight of 5
see how he plays for the
white castles in physics  of two marks but
he does not want to give that pair of bishops of
weight what we have at this moment
apart I like bishop of 2 because it
raises there can also be a dangerous
f5 at some point breaking the
contract
if we do not have that the break has
not castled no  one has castled one
imagines that zparo has already had this
position on the board because he is
playing so fast fast and very very
fast
no i am going to kaspar in this game i am going
to kasparov in this game really gary
kasparov if he is very faithful to
his style of play where not his pawn
queen but a program that many say
queen pawn very solid soft but
makes it incisive and of course he was
precisely the person who changed
what many thought  n that where the wood
is the positional games and he really
started with magnificent attacks and changed
the style of play to those queen pawn and
we are back with a g4 going at
it karjakin and at the moment it seems
that he is trying to solve his
opening problems him  he's a very
solid player and he knows he can't get into
trouble at the moment if we're going to
see what he does what do you think if we
quickly move on to another game for now
we're leaving we're going to the game of we
're not going to leave our Latin American
the great Cuban teacher who for me is
one of the favorites to win
let's go with ir domínguez let's go
with domínguez domínguez against japan is
a very fast player also if he is a
very fast player he is very very dangerous
well we have to find him for me so he
has  shown that he is a great player he did not
have a good tournament and in the endless cup
but we are playing as if he were
fast in the guy he did not spend a
minute we are going to have the p  artida of james
bond h against linier domínguez a
spanish from berlin but with 3 and we are going
to have a more solid system here with
bishop porsche 6 of porsche 6 knight
sees two knights of seven and we are going to have
this type of systems where good line
he is not risking much yet but
after bishop back we see that he has
a very solid position and nepomniachtchi
rather what he is going to try to do is to
change a couple of pieces they played f4 he
will start attacking because black is
extremely solid this knight here will
he will have to play four soon i
cavallers 6 and horse 4 a position
that is considered very solid for
black here he starts solidly
lenier dominguez
is a very incisive player
definitely just yesterday he
asked nemo how he felt for this
tournament after  a lousy tournament he
had on his physique and he told me he was
ready he likes this rhythm of the game
he likes this rhythm a lot he
is definitely a specialist in
fast games there are many
specialists it is what I like about the
tournament that we may not have at hand
or potholes but we have specialists
le quang liem nepomniachtchi nakamura they
are specialists in faster games
of course
let's remember that in the years 2000 to 2005
nobody beat them  fast moon
no one was a complete monster and
speaking of annan
maybe we can see annan
's game when we switch to d
de l'àngel's game they put themselves in the chat it
doesn't matter that there is too sincere
our principal but let's see them
all
let's see this already has many moves
the vision game against hikaru
nakamura
we have an Italian that we had already
seen in the cup without feeling this idea must
5 not taking advantage again that they are by
by by efe 2 this was a novelty that is
repeated again
we saw it from both we saw both and we see
this idea again this idea of aarón already in th
s idea of nakamura also that I play agains
or it is smooth the end of
to 15 2 and you  We hav
basically the same position that
we had between bachiller and aronian this
was the game of valle and aronian
and we have a very similar position and a
little different with file 3 where
white at the moment has this lousy
bishop on b1 that I need to play on the  4
and black is not going to allow annan to
play as 4 he is not going to allow him to
free himself we are going to see how he tries to
free the vice here because we see the
time difference and that is what we
are going to talk a lot about
today  difference in anal time has already
spent almost 67 minutes in the position and
nakamura has spent 15 seconds if you know
that it is important for everyone to know that
it is not cumulative if it is delay it is delay it
is different it is not cumulative they will
never spend the time they have  now
then well what result
will we have here for nakamura I don't know we will have
to leave him there because in rapid
anything can happen and well let's go
back to the main course garry
kasparov against serg  hey karjakin let's
go there yesterday that never
yesterday he stopped me with a lot of energy
many times
with a lot of security and what we have
here we have a couple of moves
efe 6 that seems very prudent and very
prudent the f 6 move gives the queen to the field
yes  it can't be caught so easily
at 8 it also avoids knight
touches speaking n 5 and it doesn't know what it
wanted when it could be worse
efe does it for a very good reason here it
seems to me that it stabilizes the rook structure a little more if
one plays in cali
bishop  from 7 what we were talking about the
idea of white squares in alpha is devel
ped defends the pawn from 5 prepa
es a potential knight to 5 and exact
and gary plays queen makes 2 queen
but note that positionally it is no
so favorable to speak black
change nothing else because it leaves square
the rival has a lot of pressure from the
ce column let's also see that he has a 4
after a retreat as the
next knight gentlemen well 6 well
sometimes I don't like it  to absolutely nothing
because it is very controlled and we would be
playing for the c-file with bishop b5 a
castling for the second and suddenly everything
starts to make sense
definitely
ok give 22 so here we already have
carjacking again here he is thinking
about the position for me  a slight
white advantage it seems to me that the
white pieces are going to be able to reject the control
he has over black over the
light castles and it seems to me that uniting
four is going to be very dangerous for
karjakin and 6-4 and the bishops start to put pressure
on him  they come out at the end
four years ago and erika begins to feel uncomfortable
and I wanted it to seem to me that
the opening stoppages have obtained a
slight advantage let's see if it's enough
to really beat him
I didn't remember that I
didn't remember I don't know we'll have to look for it
but it gives more than  12 what we have here and
sergey who would do who thinking
consuming time it is obvious who is
more comfortable in the position
and well kasparov played the
world championship let's remember in 1985 against
anatoly karpov who then is not
still the youngest the one who played a
world championship is still the
youngest and not only enjoy but also
win win the nonsense 22 years it
seems to me yes then well we have a case
why does he come with everything with everything remains he
has the shell 54 years old let's see if
at 54 years old gary kasparov continues to
play with these best ones it would not be what the
elite of the elite would do if
we are going to see if he can keep his
position here stable  change the queens
sergey karjakin obviously
immediately we are going to see gary take
and that is where we are going to see if he is
going to play or not gary 4 is going to play see
the ideas of the russian it is not i like this very much
bishop of 8 being gay
knows that  his opponent wants to play 14
and prepares to play bishop g6
taking advantage of the pin at the moment
i can't do that because he proposes 5
porsche forced bishop 6 and he would have
more blank material 2 caba  llos instead
of a clear one the position
by kasparov is very surprising because also
apart from 4 I can have a very
important square for the black bishop of m 2
jan efe four also pressing 7 at a
certain moment of course the ffyl has
life many times we see  that that of
2 is not a good place for the row
now many people were saying that
ponomariov
the youngest world champion but this
was that he was fide world champion that does not
necessarily count
but he is not the youngest he does not put mario
when he  he wins against ivanchuk I think that
in 2002 he became
technically well but it was not at that time
the world championship was
bifurcated that we had the fide and
the others' ies and so he was never
considered a great
total world champion
it depends on how you see it they are asking
someone knows what the grandmaster
bayern said at the closing ceremony when hoisting
master ramírez good at the
closing ceremony at the ceremo  The award-winning girl
begins to talk more about how she is
very grateful to her
family and her friends at the tabla
but it is a mention of the last special
where she mentioned
many thanks to the great teacher Alejandro
Ramírez she did not even mention
I had it I had it as my favorite
to win the tournament from the beginning if
no one believed me and to see maximum express what
I had to have faith and won the tournament
yes thank you all very much for your
comments thank you very much
send us your regards send us your
comments and well we are here
very pending  let's definitely move on to
another game we have two that we haven't
seen yet and let's move on to le quang liem
vs fabiano caruana while we
let gary think we'll be back in a couple of
minutes with the one we have with
any player from vietnam vs
fabiano caruana player here from st
louis  missouri and we are going to see
we have a small field of damm has accepted
that we have already seen the family spoke to us
several times in use twice  ces in the cup
without feels
one of his desires to control was
precisely with the exchange they give you
accepted with black and we have this
slightly more active system of four and
five which snows for a win
it is definitely not a solid game
that we live in where the  queens
left in the end
no, this is going
to the sea pretty well because we have a
strategic duel where white has
this excellent center if one
completely controls the offerer but on the other
hand the pawn of 4 particularly
can be attacked and it is not so clear
where  White is going to play because even
though it already has this structure,
first it can be broken with ef 6 and
second, Black can attack it in such a
way that White always has
to maintain what is defended, for example, in an
advance at a certain moment.  de 5
de vila would stay in the square where 5
precisely easy not to immobilize that
structure nothing simple then
we have here queen is 7 with the idea
that the rook is coming to de  8 attacking
4's pawn and le quang liem has to do with how he
holds the entire center it's not such a simple thing anymore
but on the other hand if he manages to
control the opponent's counterplay and
eventually black will be
completely positioned he has no
space
if we have a  position that is not easy
for him and well I like
fabiano caruana's position more
if it is like a style there are no people who would
like to play with the advantage of
space and there are people who like to play
against attack and in this  at the moment it is purely a
question of style who would prefer to be
you you prefer the counterattack me too
but definitely many big
media outlets would prefer white here it
is a matter of taste as well as he
comments definitely well
let's put then the last game that
we have not seen today
levon aronian against  david
navara where the armenia player here
plays with white trying to
recover from the last round of the
endless cup that well I already saw it  We are in
good spirits the last couple of days I
think he is recovered now we are going to
play a queen indian with a bishop to 6
that more or less transposes these
Catalan structures with a bishop inge 2
hitting a well known 5 pawn
with a structure of  hanging pawns here
is better for white contribution
to the end than 2
this type of structures I am playing
against this type of structures as
perez hanging both in 565 you see
here we have a doctor's rook
to press or rooks from a
rook to  one what they start with the
structure of this 8 from here what they
prepare to vara is very fast from 4 and he
says aaron and he well you want to play from
4g my guest
at last is from 8 f 4 this is a very unusual idea
where aronian  instead of playing against the
center he catches it he catches the center he
turns it into a weapon taking advantage of the fact that
black has left 5 unprotected from
4 between the knight of 5 and
totally changes the structure you see that it is already
complicated for ne  gro in a certain way
defend myself rather and develop all
his pieces if knight for 5 pawn
for 5 the problem is always the square
of that 6 I cannot play here because
the entry of the knight is very
uncomfortable white for his part is going to
try to very quickly attack the
pawn of 4 for example put a bishop at
5 mp 4-1-4-1 in row 5 that's why the
hanging perez is not very easy to advance them
that's why I was surprised by the approach of
a 4  game
because it leaves many many weaknesses yes
I would say that white is a little better and I
really like the position of his knights
for the moment they have to solve
navarra the issue that if I am
taking it jan efe 6 and with that he destroyed the
structure of the flank of  king on top of
that the hanging penalties are
totally stopped for the moment I really like
aronián's position here
I really like him I think he has a
slight advantage and I think that Navarre has not
managed to completely reject the
opening advantage  that with which aronián begins,
having the
white pieces,
aronián is a very theoretical player, very
theoretical and very knowledgeable about this type of
scheme, as he loves all those
who are Catalan, everything that is
Catalan, everything that is this type of
scheme  for aronian they are incredible
favorites to taken from 5 taken from 5 and
let's remember if the knight moves I have
knights c 6 but if you are not going to play
knight 6 what do you do you have to be
very careful that the kingside
is not attacked either if knight by  efe 7
it seems to me it is always something that must be
taken into account it may be useful to us in this
way it may be that in certain ways it is
ridiculous but it is something that must be
kept in mind horse because it is efficient it
can be an idea
if one for h 77 for the  moment if an
iron three putting absolutely
everyone and if he likes aronian's position
better yes well let's go
back then six hours break
with the grimaces what do you think if we
move on to kasparo's game  v against
definitively changing houses stoppages
against karjakin and well
we told them a good time to leave
the game because gary came back and he
hasn't made any move I think he
's got a bit stuck after the
8-bishop move that I liked a lot
after the  8 and we saw a man from Caracas but
he is making faces
and well I was thinking of finding
some time only blitz
and intimacy it is the first time I
met kasparov he was playing against
the russian olympic team it was in
2002 and he was there when against alexander
morozévich  and we were under time pressure,
not one minute each, it
was simply going up due to the increment and
kasparov arrives and sits down along with
delinquent [ __ ], he keeps looking at me
because you are out of the board
number one, the others have already finished,
we have you sit there  to see me play well
obviously a 14 year old boy
speaking against delinquent services who
will then be the third in the world and
kasparo  it goes hand in hand seeing
and experiencing a really great
experience
he is not intimidated by the mere fact of
arriving and talking to him or even
approaching him without you it makes me happy
not today for me that kasparov
was now trying to get into his mind not what
he is thinking  here kasparov the
position is strategically complex and
expanding with the 4 as I said is
the most natural thing but as soon as i remove the
knight of 5 i have to worry that
very similar to the game of l how well
against caruana that kasparov gets the center
but leaves the  weak pawns
that I have a chance to counterattack
I have to set 6 I have a rook of 8
I have all these ideas it's not that
easy so keeping them alive
he's making sure that if I play
four that I can keep the center
protected from keeping because the  4 it would be
with the idea of taking off the knight d fro
no yes but with him he pretends 6 he is very stron
for what reason because I am never going to ta
e him off 5 for every good 5  it's going
to stay there I'd have to make a rook
c 1 or something like that to get rid of the
pin even if I have 4 bishop 16 of 3 bishop
if he plays 3 of 3 which is less incisive
and we go with the fixed six rook
enters five years ago  what bothers more than rook c 1
and at the moment what would anyone who has
ideas do at the moment what he would like to
do is establish a knight on b3
but what 2 has done dandruff
as it has caused the move bishop g6
after 13-5 I don't have  times
since obviously the knight has
protected us without seeing 6 I don't know what it's like to play a
knight at 5 and that's why he plays car jacking
bishop 4 that not only attacks the knight on
f3 but if I play the pin the knight has
one I would say the most natural
That's why the defense is nailed
by 2 so that when I castle or remove
the rook from h1 I can easily remove the
knight
where the bishop would go extends two fingers
definitely the worst piece that
white has they see the structure of pawns and
the bishop of fingers does not have  e a lot of output
at the moment I would think that the bishop will
retreat in 1 for example the
exact short block a pin in e1 the knight
returns from 2 to remove the fillets
from above
efe 3 bishop g3 I think that is more or
less the maneuver  what is gad
and kaspars planning in this position where he
slowly tries to use the advantage
to the pair of bishops you know that I
like it if that maneuver castles rook c 1
bishops
of 2 because also the knight in fingers
also controls the light squares
by the  queenside
if you need to be changed diagonally
now these are a lot of moves what you
have to ask yourself is what is charity going
to do while guarding
and accommodating in such a way well well he has
gary kasparov 11 minutes against karjakin
15 minutes yes  and a gary kasparov who
consumed a lot of time like 9 minutes yes
in that move 3 where he decides to play the
pawn short instead of playing let's say the
most natural one which was 4 but also more
risks if more  risky,
but well, who is going with this machine?
I like it a little more, I would say a little
more, I like the position of the target, what
I don't like so much is that it has
spent and consumed so much time in Cádiz,
obviously, like nine minutes if I spend a
lot and then  11 minutes for the
rest of the game is not so much, it's not so much
that if the matter gets complicated, he
will have 15 minutes and see,
build rich trust for the game with 11
minutes left, there he is going
around watching the other games that
they are also very good
he grew up seeing
clearly for the truth is that I don't know I don't
have the slightest idea what the
relationship is between if there is if there is anything
between sergey karjakin and garry kasparov
I know that of course
karjakin grows up when kasparov the
legend of  the legend can
you imagine it will feel like getting to
face his hard and good after
a little long thought if it is five
played he breaks the center sergey
karjakin immediately castles hog court  ar and
as if I had already had everything
prepared and we are going to see take 4 take
with knight take the knight and pawn
for 4 and now for the moment I have a couple
of threats being white first f3
remove the knight like that that's why this 6  that
defends the pawn also because it could not
remove the knight since the plan
of 7 fell apart that defends the knight of 5 and
prepares that the bishop can be withdrawn
for the moment there are stick houses with an
isolated pawn thanks to all the changes
that have been made  passed on the point of 4
here I have to have the pair of
bishops the bishop of fingers still does not convince me much the bishop of fingers still does
not convince me much
because it does not have a big
diagonal where it can threaten something but
you know it can be interesting  at some
point press 4 press the
gift of water if it stops at a certain point
that makes them do b5 to protect it and
make it weak 6 if the pawn follows
I would definitely prefer to be on 7
or 6 a  a little more solid place
I think he wanted who has achieved
a still quite acceptable position if it
is rook 5 it is still very active
but in the long run the control of the light
squares specifically the
knight on d5 could give cary
no even thoughts  If
white's activity is better for the moment, it
still seems very
good to me. I like it a lot because of the pair of
bishops and because I can provoke other
weaknesses in the middle position. Yes,
well, greetings to all of you,
thanks for being with us and
we are well  seeing the great ogre of baku what
exactly was it is where there is a
gary was born the land of the great master dar and
gaspar of the great champion really without the
great champion of the great legend
note that mexico is not a very country
yes yes
and it is the first thing that  when they ask me
it's not that I'm a chess player and
all the first thing they tell me is more stop
first what everyone knows is
what everyone
knows grandmaster gary kaspar  ov
and well we leave the game for now
as the bishop pair says i like it
a little more for kaspar it will still not be
easy to penetrate the position because the
knight on d5 is so strong but let's
go games maybe annan's
against hikaru nakamura where to play  it is
quite extremely strong to the file 3
bishop for the 3 knight for and we have
left it in a queen of 6 then the
rook enters in a 4 and they try to establish the
break that we were talking about
a 4 rook 5 we have knight makes 4
threatening here the  queen and also the
pawn of 5 the camera decides that this
knight cannot live it eliminates it in the
end by c 4 rook by c 4 and here
the weak pawn of a 5 is eaten I don't know how but
unfortunately for jícaro the pawn
had over poison  in the fact that
now the knight can't easily
retreat from the square 5 would like to
retreat that 6 but I have the problem
so I'm going to capture 678 from 44 and the
current position
notice I was taking advantage of  or here about
the weakness of having a knight on the
edge of the game that is having a
bishop of 3 also very annoying for
attacking the rook on b5
exactly the position of anna javi is very good
I also like it a lot because it has a rook
that is pressing the column  where
do you like it a lot if at the
moment he plays 4 then
nakamura and he's right even though he
's a pawn down here vishy anand
bitten here it doesn't look like he was under
pressure under pressure annan is here with
the commune against nan the knight  2 and
knight and 5 are extremely tempting
even the move queen of 2 can be
considered taking advantage of the pin
let's remember that here if he took it
is simply an exchange of material that wins
for white because to queen f8 I don't have to
take on f8 simply to be able to play the
row 7
so let's say a move like queen of
2 can also be considered but
nadal plays the most natural knight and 5 and
i really like knight in five
problems  with the pawn of 4 with the pawn
of m3 with the knight of 5 it seems
to me that in a practical way the position of
the camera is very difficult I should
try to return some material to
return the material maybe tower for
the zinc or  something like that that
takes the pressure off me I really like
it for a moment if also when opening it to
the diagonal of v1 h7 go bothering there
I like this position it seems to me that it is
a great position here to watch with
serious possibilities of gaining a lot of
pressure  he has his opponent here
and strategically, if he managed to recover
one of the pawns, he will be very, very well
placed, very well,
let's go back to Aarón's game,
because a lot has happened, a lot has happened
in Lebón's game,
I go against the stick where we had it
stopped orsay found a tremendous idea
efe 6 plays a rod and here the
mortal people the normal ones take away the
knight but aronian says why
am I not going to take away a rook from 1 pawn for 5 pawn
for 5 and only have  I have a pawn in this
position aaron I only have a
pawn for a piece for a knight but
see what pawns what pawns we have here and
the development
and this king is going to be threatened beautiful I am going
to have and give as a queen f5 the file four
give me efe  5 mf 72 of course I will
be with a 6 to block the queen
on square f 5 and soon there will be
a super attack on this 28 and they danced
yen here sacrificing a piece trying to
take away here as the scenario
good grip has its light game  advantage
nothing is happening says good
to me a quite quite good position
we see I think that in a practical way it is
difficult to play these positions with
black even though maybe
yes good because of the time because of the pressure
because it is more natural and play
attacking move yes  that finding
defensive plays many times in
quick times is worth more these ideas
of quickly attacking than putting pressure
and that you defend yourself from your rival now in
a purely theoretical way it seems to me that the
sacrifice must be correct the
pawns are very strong it is difficult to
find a way to get all the
pieces out of black and
the minimum minimum is going to cost black
one piece there is going to be no way he
can completely reject a pawn it
is 6 without  deliver some material
it seems to me that aronian will win this
game although perhaps the computer
will tell them that it is zeros or even
give black an advantage it seems to me that in
a practical way it is a great game
so I am not surprised by the
position  black of the pieces that have a
lot of
development there is no development because one
of the
and this is where we go because already
after 6 already from the 6 knight efe six what
one imagines this by fcc torre by
efe
we have here on the board a torre
tera ha  sacrificed levon aronian
a torrentera
wow but note also how
black's position is on the flank
rook 87 if he gets to have fun he gets to
have fun levon gets here he enters with the
queen to ef  e 5 at the moment threatens
just take nf6 if at some point
I am going to threaten file 4 to take on h
7 maybe rook 4
precisely the rook is going to transfer
to the kingside and now again how do
you defend how do you defend here
navarra against such an attack with
all white's pieces when
you have a rook here in sevran at 8 which is
not very useful if you will have to take
great care of the bar so that they don't give you a mate
and soon soon if there is no
increase you don't have to increase the
delay  there are 21 how many delays there are
how many types of delay or according to 10
seconds of law
the rhythm is 25 minutes with 10 seconds
of delay for each move and it is different it is a
delay move it is not cumulative
well give me f5 navarra stops again to
think let's get back quickly  the game
of the day
aaron I already took away the prominence they
camped with towers for it is the 6th is that
here they come here is the show that
we have they inspire me
[Laughter]
but we must remember that here  here
we have the great tournament with gary kasparov
but it is not only winning and it is not only winning
a super player here we have aronián a
player who without a doubt has had a
year and see what is coming if one was left without
any fear here to play and navarra
cardiac arrest lenier domínguez lee kuan
yew david navara we have the truth that is
not known it is a whole cast what we
have here I think he has played checkers of
8 and we are going to see if he has something
here we are going to see if he has something here it
seems to me  that yes rook 4x4 you play enter with
everything here aaron is obviously the rook or
is he going to pass either in 4 h 4 to attack
here the weaknesses on the flank and king
rook efe 6 of what david navara plays
were rooks 7 leaving the pawn  df 6
but note that if I eat the pawn df 6
bishop g7 and
black's position begins
to improve live rook c 4 now
now this is the problem is
navarra's problem appointment with either of
the two go to file 4  and who is going to
defend the h-pawn  7 yes but what else is he
going to do let's see if he plays h 8
I have to worry queen about efe 6 that
for the time being good you still have a bishop
of 7
we won't see but I think he has to
play king g8 if he plays bishop g7 or rook
g7 let's say the whole axis seven bishops
four threatens to kill one and I can't
take because it's still mate queen in
seven for example it doesn't protect because it's
still mate the rook is pinned
exactly
I think it has to be removed it's already made it
re 8 to 0 8 come on  Let's see where he can
culminate us, let's remember it's one tower
less what Aronian has here one
torrentera less than what the former
Armenian grandmaster
Olympic champion has here
and let's see
and after eight it smells to me that there must
be something there must  there should be something bishop of
four and the most logical thing not of four the
most logical move simply puts more
pressure on the position and allows me to
play a rook h 4 allows me to play a
queen for efe 6 let's see if de aronian
manages to annihilate this a  lfil 4 in which
file 4 has played and we are going to see if
a gang can be defended I don't see much
coordination on Black's part I don't see
what he is going to do
after bishop and 4 what he can do is
that this problem is  fully
adapted it
is so slow and so pathetic yes really
because this has also been all rachid
h4 says that the defenders of the h7
plan are over because we remember
yes yes it gives more than 7 I will always have a
bishop efe 4 that removes the  queen of the
seventh and who is going to defend h 7 who
is the one who is going to defend h 7 maybe
do yes yes even if he makes rook of rooks
c 8 17 to defend the seventh
follows the theme of bishop efe when
everything definitely falls here for
navarra but what a nice
rook sacrifice levon aronian has played with and
it's over I think after bishop e 4
I don't see how he can be saved there are many pieces
attacking h7 and h7 barely falls, everyone enters
the king of h8 is left without
defense and  what is the law of pawns 35 and n6
without nin  no fear
no fear no fear at all
[Music]
I think lonia I think I
think aronian has already done the hard part and I
don't see how it is that Navarre leaves the final
Navarre with 4 minutes really has
very little time left here  the grandmaster of
the czech republic is going to start with a
loss
it seems to me against aronian arónica el
majado calm down and he knows what the
attack is and he will see navarra worried
worried about what is happening he plays the
whole c8 precisely what he had
said rooks of 8 preparing
do that because as for this
reig and 4 I don't know but not the same or rook h
4 maybe he has played rook h 4 I don't think it
's very arty it has to be I imagine
that the idea not if you played rook c 8 is
to make 13 7  but the problem is that he is
going to enter with the queen jan efe six he was going
to enter with the night rook 7 we are
in the last moments it seems to
me that the player from the czech republic is from here
before we return with gary of
course not all but each  go  z how
sad how sad this position
on the black side rook h 4
pressing no yes yes here the computer
the best queen c7
bishop efe 4
the best but there is no more because he
was making you 6 exactly and
how do you remove how to  I am making these plans
of 6 and even, for example,
torres and 7 equal to the steak 4 also
roasting, it is simply that it has not been
completely finished, it is treated as a
manga by torres hands saying 37 give me
by the French 6 he took advantage of here
that he is nailed to  the rook yes yes
reiche 8 what exactly
did he do i can't eat this pawn
that rules 8 first axis 8 i guess i
can eat on h7 i don't see the big
problem with him we are not what we are
waiting for we are still there with calories 47
and i am  making queens of 6 I am
putting everything there it is not totally
lost eva torres for h7 torre for
alexia 6.7
until the threat for example here if I
play check and you play here I have everything for
pending issues and enter then
cs everything with aronian is totally lost
david navara we will return eventually
to see how they finished it but
this game is over it is a good rook for h7
at any moment the
player from the czech republic is going to give up because he
is already totally lost let's go back to
garrido gary let's go  with garry kasparov
that what has happened with garry kasparov
incredible what he has done to aronian will be
the first winner of the day with a
totally brilliant game mary shanthi
come on we let him do rat
this long-awaited day today
definitely the field is jul 6 efe  an
efe bishop 7 - to the game of garry
kasparov against sergey karjakin
efe rook of 8 f 5 and well he tries to gain
space here he tries to gain space
dandruff 2 to compensate for his isolated pawn
he exchanges a pair of rooks and
says well no  I want it to win, it's in
your space, I don't want it, too, to have my
own game, take, take, the bishop of 25
seems to me to be a very successful move since you
give  after g5 I am stopping the entrance
of the bishop in many places
it seems to me that g5 is a very good move
very very good bishop of 3 reiche 713 two
neighbors so it was a
provocative maneuver and 7-5 to try to generate
weaknesses for him  even more weaknesses
on the queenside yes I really like
this position but well let's see the
clocks we have two minutes 59 for
kaspar against carjacking 7 minutes
let's remember that no delay is not
cumulative delay well what happens here is that
it would be what I would do here  he has a
very solid position i find it
difficult for kaspar to penetrate this
position i don't think he is inferior because of
the pair of bishops really but
well we already have the first mate of the day
we have the first mate of the day
where aarón's game against barba ya has already finished
bombshell
by algeria arabia against
navarra how the game ends it ends like this
queen g6 check we had already talked about that
he can't finally play on 7 because of rook h 8
yes  rook 7 play queen h 5 he threatened mate
unstoppable as he
didn't stop the filter of four rook h 8
let them finish him in good style win
then leo on the canvas against david
navara let's go to other incredible games
incredible game yes he has
played here
levon aronián if here they say a bombshell from
haro really near a game she
saw from aronián that the knight
in 50 well we have another game that
has ended yes it is net against
lenier domínguez that ended in a draw
what do you think if we see I think that  review
so that we will review that game a little
later it seems to me that it was very solid
that they entered the end of rooks where
absolutely nothing happened he in jr with the
black pieces starts the tournament in a good way
since there is no solid sound
tables with jacques  and it's an excellent
result if absolutely nothing happened
in the game and well it ends in a draw
so I put myself up and against
domínguez's line we go to the game he
didn't make me  nothing happened yet the
sentry box game let's move on to the anal game against
jícaro has already definitely changed
this position in a way that surprises me
for a moment black has two
extra pawns but he is going to drop at least
167 he is under attack 4  under attack at 6
under attack we had left him here as
the knight 5 a knight sees 7 c 4
and although we are going to go on horseback for 6-5
taking advantage of the fact that the knight needs
defense here it seems that he has calculated very
well expensive because maybe annan was
relying on the knight move this 4
that here attacks the knight and attacks the
rook but in we have rook at 4 that
attacks counterattacks the rook
knight of 3 every month 6 and again
because the knight is defending the
rook the queen piece is dawning  from 2
we exchange pieces and after dawn
6 until the current position he has two
pawns to chew but one is going to
fall soon it will also fall in
four is that I do not like the
position on the part of d anymore
yes  I think I like
black's position simply because that's how
materialistic today signs said and 4 is
so easy for him to fall but for the
moment after the queen of 6 in amman he
has to solve certain problems
because he barely plays as a free pawn
something to pay attention to, for example, if I take a
rook at 67 I have to first take care
of what they are eating me at 4 and
I would prefer rather less 34 if that's why
I keep the rook at 4 if I keep the rook at
[Music]
otherwise I can't give myself  the luxury of
we have here with us a special guest
in the studio well let's see the
players here they go against hikaru
nakamura on camera
I think nakamura as we said a
player who is of the age that is
problematic for nani I think this is not
going  to be the exception we have
important moves but he has
only recovered an anal pawn but see the
problem for where baby knight v6 takes me
to enter 4 the pawn of b2
extremely fragile and well already a danger
here to win well we have
to have a guest here at the tournament
his first time playing in san luís and
well he has been immortalized but
we have to have the grandmaster david
navara good afternoon everyone to lose I
don't have an almost spanish surname but
no i'm not  Spanish
and I have some problems with my Spanish
because I lack practice
a very interesting game and sorry
where I have it here on my
monitor if that is where you want to start to
see that here where the interesting thing was is
you were surprised that giving the horse
is not  complicated to prepare some other
mine but since I made a mistake I
do not play this line regularly but
this time if it was to play some other
line it is to confuse the preparation
I did not know
44 of 57 as theory
with a friend and they play f4 a little
different from 4 and here  I think he already had
this idea that taking
in the position would be a bit worse
for black and here he knows how under this
line
how
something like that I'm not sure already  that the
horse of 6 you
may not think after the
position of this guide and wolf error
after horses five I have to
do something the bonus has said that the
horse of seven would be better but I
am not sure because plants can
change into horses and  in this
position i have problems that threaten to
play knight
4 eventually
eventually the position is good
let's look at the position maybe a little more
intriguing we still have to see
kasparov's game so if you
can give us your impression after
knight f6 take nf6 and which one  it's his
feeling here in this position
here already a little later
4 but he could
still play a 36
ok
with a cave you've seen a thousand variations
I think this position is still in
order possibly three would be better
I'm not sure but I don't think the
position would be so bad
but possibly it is very very difficult
for black to defend and
possibly he could try the march
and 7a
and what was the mistake  r decisive do you think
possibly some this some of those
plays in plays called 8
yes i think queen of 8 and he enters with the
rook of 44 in this position and now
it is a better position well maybe he
can join us we are looking
at garry kasparov's position  that you are going to see
that what has happened we have this endgame
of bishops we have equality of material
where the players have agreed to a draw
it seems to me that nothing is happening not
feasting with f5 in this position
black could try
because because you are 4 it would be  bad
to the carriers dies 4 nov end the
fillet 5 end so here they draw
the russians garry kasparov and sergey
karjakin has also won set a
camera maybe we can see how
this game ended
the year left rooks of seven we entered
with the knight on b6 and  he can't
defend anand against the passed pawn
here he must three which is extremely strong
not
all here 94 are many pawns rook of
one and in the end completely lost
for which  they have spent a lot of stress to
finish the nice game of three that
indirectly defends the pawn df 7
since kings 3 I have ideas of rook 1 and
b2 or pawn for three I have rook f1 and b2
nice move of 3 wins then yes expensive
nakamura good david  thanks for
joining us here here in spanish
maybe we will have the remaining game of
le quang liem against fabián a sister
the second microphone of the lime and with
family we can also see on camera
we already have the last moments it seems
that they are two very strong passed pawns
for fabián a carvalho on the
queenside we hope this ends cani
and here we have him here on camera the
american who
won his strategy really won his strategy where
we see that he has liquidated the
kingside in the center of his
chosen opponent someone when here  now
with seconds pure seconds we can now
return to the board
where we are closely following the
position of course hacker king g8 g5
is where we have here  the position already with
seconds we have second
and how well with 23 seconds and fabiano
with 33 seconds definitely lost
the position here for the player from
vietnam plays b2 to tactical tactics and
from caruana torres it seems 6 rooks x of 4
take advantage of the fact that the pawn is entering  b1
take take le quang liem abbas that the
resource has been found crown the
american player rook 7 threatening
some kind of perfect but this is not going to
give and this is not going to give he just has
to guard against perpetuals i
think rook
82 me  it seems indicated the
main threat kill 2 don't kill and g7
after rook d because 7 rook g8 rook
next mate has to get rid of
and that's why it seems to me that all
the brakes in the most successful play serious
and 8 which is a very good idea  similar wait to
see which rook is going to take on g7 take
rook from resumes the threat rooks of 8
and rooks that seven I killed and here I
think good
but how this works I'm going to win
the queen doesn't win me  na the lady
that what she has not seen that I am not
seeing hacking
plays all real 7 but what was wrong with
rook g8
but they have not seen rook g8
rooks of 8-7 here since here since I
take the queen next  I
'm not seeing something human, I'm after,
they haven't seen, they haven't seen, and well it goes
away then with efe 8 sorry 13 8
here it takes off tower at 7 and let's go here and
how the mate is going to go away caruana gives
up horrible blonder horrible blonder
from fabiano  caruana
impressive impressive how he
dropped a position he wins a
tenth from fabiano caruana
but as I said this was the
simple one I'm going to repeat rook g2 he
simply won in this position instead of
what he did I didn't understand it at
all fast rook  it was to cover the
column of the mind
seven towers towers 107 we take out the
problems no here there is no problem
so lawful network
totally lost here I am and instead
of that he plays this very strange thing that
already loses directly  If I had
played check I can't play 7 or here
for mate here and check I have to play he
makes this one move
and I take the queen they haven't seen this they
didn't see either and rook at 7 which seems I
don't know if it also wins I have to  calculate
check here
but for the action
and auction he is not here and he has no way
of preventing
fabiano caruana that blonder of
fabiano caruana
in addition to how he has let his
position live won won winner winner
fabiano was like an album like a
curse or the same as in  the rapids
from paris are here losing the first
to le quang liem in a game won
cannady sima
has a queen there were a couple of
ideas mate's ideas were there but a
grandmaster with a minute are memories
coverage there is not even I'm not there I'm
not  I'm using the module and
it occurred to me in five seconds
but you have to play you have to bring the
tower to the defense
buf
incredible
well let's start then nobody knows about
cattle they are cows exactly  learn
learn the public learn the public
won are cows won are low and what a
good game tell us and see what were the
results of round number one of the
rapid and kasparov draw against
karjakin in this first round
anna nakamura nakamura wins win lee
kwan well wins him  to fabiano caruana a
number of those things really ideal
against navarra aronián wins and well net
draws with lenier a very solid game
I am part of a very very solid
well well we had 2 here
I am reviewing what has happened
what happened here that's it  lost we
don't have two plenary sessions passed
a nice one a very simple tactic
it was just a matter of getting rid of
mate
that's all I had to
do respects
efe two towers but so far
blocking blocking ideas tower 2
was the most natural thing to attract  the
tower back of
course incredible what has happened good and
very sad thank you very much to all of
you for following this transmission
you can't  in moving because the
next round is coming up the second round this one
of sanluis rapids and clips you
can't miss it thanks to you for the
comments for being with us in
this transmission and you can't move
because the round will be within two and a
half let's go  to start half an
hour of services and half an hour later we
will be with you in the second round
let's review today garry kasparov would
contrast load that in a duel of the
extremely solid russian he put on car
jacking shell he did not make a single
bad move  but it was not enough to
win
anal
I think he had a good position against
the camera but a scam camera and
rather you get to have his material
and suddenly another entrance from horse
to horse b6 horse to four horses
by b2 who has struck down  to the former
world champion nice match in chicago and
as I repeat he is a difficult rival paraná and he
is one of the favorites to win this
tournament and we also had him and how well
c  against fabiano caruana a game that
there was a blogger on the part of the
american grandmaster could not understand
what happened it is difficult to understand
brilliant brilliant brilliant that
we stayed with a guest who was
shocked
2700 who did not know that what had
happened
incredible wow incredible
beauty prize game like yesterday in san javier I already
love it when they say it's a 10
prize beauty prize is what we're going
to give here to aronián and we had aleppo with
domínguez
in a very solid game extremely
solid in reality that of course  we did not see
that absolutely nothing will happen it was an
anti berlin in order to 5 between an f 4
and this structure despite the fact that it gives
white some advantage it is not much the
bishop will always return 8 to
defend the weak squares that
we have in  f5 and without access to ef 5 it is not
easy to create a backfire here black
can attack the isolated pawn he
eventually exchanges the dh pawns for the df one
which then leaves an endgame  draw since
white's queenside everything is
quite vulnerable and as soon as I advance
this pawn is isolated so there
is really no way to advance the
lv7 52 of 4 rook 4 and if
position 95 is already greatly simplified here there is
no problem  your reform 6 is not
possible it is possible but it is not going to give him
anything because the data has to
return very quickly to the city that the
pawn does not enter if I manage to change rooks
he wins on black because that is
quite far away at times and we are
in  c5 I can take a block and they
take 5 494 taking advantage of the pawn, yes, so
of all the flowers that he doesn't see these
draws to cadiz in levon he only knows two
words since as we started
today garry's game
was also not  the most interesting but the others
said here we are let's see us
[Music]
cádiz and levon aronián with their beauty award
wow what a round you can't miss it
the second round is coming and it will start in a
few minutes where  we will have a second
round as tell us then how is
the second round going to be here of the fast one would
have san luis-la kasparov
we can ask for a layer 2 and well that plus
a camera with whites they are fast
gasparón blacks
passes the difficult one to win and it does not go  from
here cardia loads and ground let's see
what he has to get out of his old weapon
I think that hopefully it will be like this navarras
caruana
for all those who have done
that they need to recover after
their first round they have 20 minutes to
do it because in 20 minutes  they can
find against themselves so it
's a good game not caroní
brilliant in his first round in
economy in a calm game that he didn't
play badly just a calm duel
yes and it seems to me that aronian if he continues to
play well he is going to have a lot of problems
new well we also have lenier dominguez
against anna from great great great
duel in the world of 2012
2012 world champion of 2012
rapid against nan excellent duel not
the best nad  latin american adorer against
andan and well he charges here against lee
kuan and it also seems like a great duel that
would make that now with the white pieces he
will really be able to try
and well thanks for following us thanks
for being here with us greetings to
all of you on the day of  today we will have
the first three rounds of this fast
of the first phase of this tournament and
well what do you think if we take a
break
if it seems to me that good let's give ourselves a
little break we progress with you
in about 10 minutes more or less 10 to 15
minutes 10  10 to 15 minutes we are
returning 5 minutes
before 15 minutes we return with you which
will be the second round we will be
back at 2 15 minutes
before the next round begins and here
we will be with you you have already
heard it excellent round do not
miss it  we return in 15 minutes with
you
[Music]
to extend management work and for
investment
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
and
[Music]
[Applause]
to
[M  úsica]
[Applause]
[Music]
i
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
y
[Music]
no
i
[Music  ]
[Music]
and
but
[Music]
then
and
[Music]
i
yes
[Music]